let me try to ask a question that's
often brought up about autonomous
vehicles
and it might be fun to see if you have
anything anything interesting to say
which is about the trolley problem
so uh a trolley problem is a interesting
philosophical construct
of uh that highlights and there's many
others like it
of the difficult ethical decisions that
uh we humans have before us in this
complicated world
uh so the specifically is the choice
between
if you were forced to choose uh to kill
a group x of people versus a good why of
people like
one person if you didn't if you did
nothing you would kill one person
but if you would kill five people and if
you decide to swerve out of the way you
would only kill one person
do you do nothing or you choose to do
something you can construct all kinds of
sort of
ethical experiments of this kind that
i think at least on a positive note
inspire you to think about like
introspect
what are the the
physics of our morality and there's
usually not good
answers there uh i think it people love
it because it's just an exciting thing
to think about
i think people who build autonomous
vehicles usually roll their eyes
because uh this is not this
one as constructed this like literally
never comes up
in reality you never have to choose
between killing
and one like one of two groups of people
but i wonder if you can speak
to is there some something interesting
to use an engineer of autonomous
vehicles that's within the trolley
problem
or maybe more generally are there
difficult ethical decisions
that you find that the algorithm must
make
on the specific version of the trailer
problem which one would you do
if you're driving the question itself is
a profound
question because we humans ourselves
cannot answer and that's the very
point uh i guess i would kill both
um yeah humans i think you're exactly
right and that you know humans are not
particularly good
like they kind of phrased like what
would a computer do but like
humans you know are not very good and i
actually oftentimes
think that you know freezing and kind of
not doing anything because
like you've taken a few extra
milliseconds to just process and then
you end up
like doing the worst of the possible
outcomes right so um i i do think that
as you've pointed out it can be a bit of
a distraction and it can be a bit of a
kind of a red herring i think it's an
interesting philos
discussion in the realm of philosophy
right but in terms of what you know how
that affects
the actual engineering and deployment of
self-driving vehicles
i um it's not how you go about building
a system right we've talked about how
you engineer a system
how you uh go about evaluating the
different components and
you know the safety of the entire thing
how do you kind of
inject the you know various model based
safety based arguments and you're like
yes your it parts the system
you know you reason about the
probability of a collision the severity
of that collision right uh
and that is incorporated and there's you
know you have to properly reason about
the uncertainty that flows through the
system right so
you know those uh you know
factors definitely play a role in how
the cars don't behave but they tend to
be more of like the immersion behavior
and what you see like you're absolutely
right that these you know
clear uh theoretical problems that they
you know you you don't recover that
in system and really kind of being back
to our previous discussion of like what
what you know what
what you know which one do you choose
well you know oftentimes
like you made a mistake earlier like you
shouldn't be in that situation
uh in the first place right and in
reality the system comes up
if you build a very good safe and
capable driver
you have enough uh you know clues uh in
the environment that
you drive defensively so you don't put
yourself in that situation right
and again you know it has you know this
if you go back to that analogy of you
know precision and recall like okay you
can make it
you know very hard trade off of the i1
but like neither answer is really good
but what instead you focus on is kind of
moving
the whole curve up and then you focus on
building the right capability and the
right defensive driving so that you know
you
don't put yourself in a situation like
this
you